ciao a tutti ciò che vorrei condividere
di oggi è la mia esperienza con il
bullismo esistono nelle forme di
bullismo esistono riforme di aggressione
da quella fisica a quella verbale da
parte quello secondo me forme di
bullismo e forme di pressione si
nascondono anche dietro gesti molto più
piccoli andava in seconda media e c'era
questo ragazzino nella classe di fianco
che ricordo ancora mirava del [ __ ]
lo faceva sempre quando io mi stavo
allontanando magari all'uscita di scuola
lo faceva quando non lo vedevo lo faceva
perché altri suoi compagni
ridevano e quindi questa cosa ma che non
bisogna sentire più forte davanti ai
loro occhi magari forse lo aiutava
augurando schon del fatto che secondo me
lui forse gay non gli ho mai detto
giusta per il nostro video chat e vi sto
parlando è l'unica cosa che ricordo è
che ogni volta che mi insultava mi
uccideva forse perché da una parte io
non avevo la forza non ho mai avuto la
forza di rispondere a quegli insulti non
hanno la forza di seguire i consigli
degli amichetti che mi facevano ma tu
spaccargli la faccia trani a catena del
motorino sfondo ai e lo zio che cazzo e
django ragazzino forse se avesse reagito
in maniera più forte l'avessi minacciato
anche avessi parlato la sua lingua
forse lui avrebbe smesso problema è che
io quella lingua non ho mai parlato e
non lo parlo il problema è che si
capisce e per me è sempre stato da
piccolo un motivo di vergogna dobbiamo
andare a scuola quindi a parte che i
giovani star male se sapevo che c'erano
delle gite insieme con quella classe di
tavo questa cosa ovviamente mi ha
portato a chiudermi tantissimo non
vedevo l'ora che finissero le medie e
non vedevo l'ora di andarmene al liceo
infatti è stato per me più facile sia
perché in classe avevo il mio cugino che
era molto più bulletto di me quindi un
pochino mi proteggeva almeno una cosa
che ho scoperto più avanti col tempo lì
per lì non me ne ero reso conto e sia
perché sono diventato bravissimo a fare
il camaleonte cercava un pochino di
leggere che avevo davanti e fare in modo
di trattarlo e dire a quella persona
quello che voleva sentirsi dire internet
mi ha dato la possibilità di di aprirmi
mi sono reso conto che là fuori
esistono molte più persone simili a noi
quando non pensiamo magari non abbiamo
avuto la fortuna di avere la stessa
classe magari non abbia avuto la fortuna
di incontrarla lavoro e magari in alcuni
casi non abbiamo ancora avuto una
fortuna di averla casa la fuori state
sicuri che esistono persone che non
pensano che voi siete sbagliati per come
siete
non c'è cosa più bella dell'askoll tarsi
e della accettarsi per come si è
nell'essere apprezzati per ciò che si è
veramente io non credo che queste
persone possono vantare lo stesso
privilegio per finire questo video torno
in ii all
all'inizio e al bulletto che si trattava
di merda alle medie stiamo parlando di
tre giorni dopo apprestando ho già avuto
le soddisfazioni video e libri era
diligenza quelle cose fine e ricordo che
stavo ristorante per certo punto sento
questa voce dice guglielmo io mi giro e
vado avanti questo cameriera metto a
fuoco la sua faccia e mi rendo conto che
lui e lui mi fa
ti ricordi di me per un istante avuto la
tentazione di dire di certo in me
ricordi detto se quello che non ha
rovinato completamente le medie certi
che facciamo in giro il mio di [ __ ] e
parlando scoperti e poi mi sono detto no
non rispondergli così
pregate quindi mi ricordo che li facevi
una cosa tipo guardano come mi ricordo
vivamente i seri cioè lice ci provava a
farmi ricordare che fosse fa come anno
nella sezione c continua e sempronio
amici dichiara luisa è stato di tipo
qualche a digiuno non me lo ricordo
assolutamente le news e gli disse guarda
che però farà fare sante grazie finì lì
e mentre mi versava l'acqua io ho
proprio pensato a come la vita sia
assurda non dirgliene quattro iene
patrioti nei 40 e non l'ho fatto
e sapete perché per come non mandava di
essere un bullo cioè non devono dare il
potere di tirarmi fuori e la cattiveria
arretrata nei suoi confronti
magari non l'ha mai vissuta penserà che
sia una cosa molto più stupida di quanto
di quanti non la faccia una cosa
positiva però che questo video non è per
quelle persone per chi sa esattamente
cosa sto parlando
sappiate che la violenza contrario di
come ho fatto io
va combattuta e va combattuta con
intelligenza non va combattuta
lasciate se non avete la forza voi i
vostri genitori oi vostri amici agiscano
per voi non avete vorrei parlare con
tutte quante le autorità il cui compito
è quello di proteggervi perchè le vere
conseguenze che fanno male sono quelle
che vengono al momento in cui quello che
fa per niente io ve lo auguro perché è
una sensazione meravigliosa
arriverà un momento in cui il cerchio si
chiuderà e voi non dovrete fare niente
non dovrete dare nessun tipo di testo vi
basterà semplicemente non dare la mancia